quando mi chiedono quale sia il mio
corso di studi e dico che faccio sigen
imation di solito creato non poca
confusione
alcuni pensano che faccia grafica altri
architettura fino arrivare alle
animazioni che ci si avvicina se non
fosse che intendono quelle anni villaggi
turistici per questo tende a
semplificare dicendo che faccio le
esplosioni nei film
in realtà queste esplosioni vale a dire
i visual effects of sex sono solo nei
situa parte di quest ambito chigi non è
come potrebbe sembrare un acronimo del
mio nome e cognome
basta per computer graphics la computer
grafica la disciplina informatica volta
l'utilizzo di asse 3 d a che vengono
attaccati dei programmi definiti shader
che possono per esempio essere tipo
fondo blin ne so tropico e che tramite
un processo chiamato rendering vengono
ora sterilizzati per modificare la
natura vettoriale ottenere immagini
bidimensionali
tutto chiaro no fo sembra di complesso
ma in realtà siamo costantemente
circondati dalla computer grafica
la troviamo nei film nei videogiochi
nelle pubblicità nei prodotti di
intrattenimento in generale in
produzione viene seguito un processo
molto preciso in gergo pipe line che se
dividendo in preproduzione produzione e
post produzione come vedete viso le fs
sono solo tra gli ultimi stati prima di
far esplodere il nostro personaggio
infatti dobbiamo modellarlo texturizzato
ovvero colorarlo montargli uno scheletro
chiamato rig illuminarlo e poi la regina
vita animandolo questo è un settore
molto specializzato e vien da sé che non
può essere una sola persona a occuparsi
di tutta la pipe line la capacità di
lavorare in team è richiesta perché
essenziale per la sopravvivenza
chi non è in grado di collaborare
rallenta tutto il processo e danneggia
anche l'azienda ora passiamo al secondo
punto focale del titolo di questo talk
tavolo nucleo si è una malattia
infettiva virale causata dal virus di
epstein barr
ma qui non mi dilungo dato che non è il
mio ambito cosa c'entra la mononucleosi
con la cg assolutamente nulla
l'unico punto di congiunzione sono io
nel primo semestre di quest'anno
accademico o realizzate insieme altri
cinque mie compagne un vero gioco
sull'area lenti
non avevamo alcuna esperienza quasi
nessuna conoscenza ma qualche modo
dovevamo costruire da zero un mondo
interattivo
lo scopo non era solamente quello di
ottenere un prodotto visivamente bello e
funzionale ma anche soprattutto
dimostrerà di essere in grado di
lavorare insieme ad altre persone
[Musica]
il tema che le università ci aveva
segnato era la divina commedia
su questa base abbiamo sviluppato un
gioco ambientato in una metropolitana in
cui ogni fermata rappresentava in chiave
moderna un peccato capitale ad abitare
questo ambiente erano quindi sette
personaggi una parola fashion blogger
per la superbia un neo capitalista per
l'avarizia una sensuale dama gatto per
la lussuria un soldato leone per l'ira
un maiale appassionato di fast food per
la gola una vipera panca per l'invidia è
un barbone senza meta per l'accidia
questi che vedete sono dei concept e si
inseriscono nella pre produzione
la concept art è la base da cui partirà
la modellazione dei personaggi quindi
aiuterà i character artist che loro
volta aiuteranno gli animatori e così
via non avere un design deciso e preciso
fin dall'inizio non ci porterà molto
lontano
un aspetto molto importante da
considerare in ogni progetto è
sicuramente il budget ma in questo caso
non stiamo parlando di soldi bensì di
budget poligonale un modello 3d infatti
è costituito da facce o poligoni di cui
maggiore il conto è maggiore la qualità
ma di conseguenza anche il peso in
memoria nei videogiochi viene utilizzata
una modellazione definita lo poli ovvero
con il minor numero di faccio possibili
nel nostro caso all'inizio abbiamo
ottenuto tutto molto basso per evitare
sprechi solo con il tempo aveva imparato
a gestire il budget ma a quel punto era
necessario tornare indietro cestinare
parte della modellazione rifarla è stato
snervante ve lo assicuro però è servito
perché guardando al confronto non sa
come facessimo ad accettare le prime
versioni
il mio ruolo principale è stato quello
di art director cioè responsabile delle
scelte artistiche come per esempio
quelle cromatiche o di design di
ambienti e personaggi come quelli che
abbiamo visto prima
questa è sicuramente la parte più
creativa ma anche la cui determinante
per lo sviluppo futuro del progetto
ora provate a immaginare come possa
essere cercare di mettere d'accordo un
gruppo di artisti le discussioni sulla
giusta sfumature di blu da dare una
panchina si sono dilungati per settimane
credo sia facile pensare che se un
prodotto e divertente lo sia anche a
realizzarlo ma non è sempre così creare
un vero gioco non è come giocarci è una
corsa contro il tempo per cercare di
rispettare le tempistiche ed evitare gli
imprevisti che potrebbero mandare tutto
all'aria
quando si lavora in un gruppo c'è sempre
quella regola non scritta che dice che
c'è sempre almeno un componente che
lavora meno degli altri e se non c'è
vuol dire che sei tu e quindi il
raccordo con i miei compagni è diventato
sempre più difficile chiaramente quando
si lavora con i propri amici si scoprono
lati nuovi della loro personalità
spesso è difficile dare parere sinceri
senza rischiare di ferire i loro
sentimenti ma altrettanto spesso la
confidenza rimuove ogni filtro ci possa
essere troppo schietti le questioni
personali si mescolano a quelle
lavorative creando dinamiche non proprio
facile da sostenere
quindi a forza di scontri su argomenti
inutili consegne che non andavano come
previsto e sotto il peso della
responsabilità di gestione la mia salute
mentale e fisica ha cominciato a
logorarsi chiaramente non sto dicendo di
esser mia amata per pura stanchezza ma
credo che l'ammontare di stress abbia
danneggiato quanto possibile il mio
sistema monetario
così un giorno contavo i secondi che
mancavano alla consegna successiva e
quello dopo ero costretto a letto compra
che i 40 di febbre
senza la possibilità di muovermi
turiamoci di lavorare la mia ansia è
triplicata non sapevo come avrei fatto a
recuperare il tempo perso l'assenza le
elezioni quando ci avrei messo a guarire
dopo questa prima fase schizofrenica
cominciato a capire di non poter fare
assolutamente nulla se non riposare e
aspettare di guarire
improvvisamente il progetto che stava
occupando ogni momento delle mie
giornate non aveva più alcuna importanza
lo ammetto mi son scelta stupida per
tutta l'ansia provata prima quel momento
finalmente riuscivo a osservare la
situazione da un punto di vista nuovo
letteralmente quello del letto di
staccarsi è servito perché mi ha
permesso di elaborare razionalmente la
situazione trovando me una posizione
esterna
così quando sono tornata anche sapevo
non poco da recuperare riusciva andare
oltre il vicolo cieco che mi si era
parato davanti coglievo difetti che
prima notavo perché troppo immersa nel
lavoro spesso credo ci concentriamo
troppo sull'obiettivo da raggiungere
paradossalmente talmente tanto da
perderlo di vista
è come se ci trovassimo di fronte a una
strada magari breve ma piena di ostacoli
piuttosto che cercare di percorrere
questa via potrebbe essere più facile a
girarla ottenendo lo stesso risultato
nel mio caso era maggiore del tempo
impiegato con l'ansia di non riuscire a
consegnare di quello effettivamente
produttivo bastava davvero staccare la
spina per rendersi conto di non aver
intrapreso la strada giusta
questo settore ci obbliga gli
straordinari per ge sempre troppo da
migliorare e poco tempo per farlo ma non
siamo delle macchine piuttosto che
gettarsi a capofitto sul lavoro
rischiando di sbagliare di doverlo
rifare o piuttosto che passare notti in
bianco inconcludenti potrebbe essere
meglio prima analizzare il problema
suddividerle sotto problemi e poi passa
relazione un divideteli impera diciamo
un po rivisitato quest'ora lì si
richiede tempo ma non è certamente tempo
perso anzi ci impedisce di burden
altrettanto in corso d'opera e ogni caso
ricordiamo che stiamo facendo un
prodotto di intrattenimento
lo scopo è divertire e come se non anche
divertendosi
questa storia si conclude con un happy
ending abbiamo affrontato a esame
stanchi ma soddisfatti innocente non
pensato i nostri sforzi
vorrei mangiarmi con voi mostrandomi il
3 del nostro gioco
sabato l
[Applauso]
[Musica]